[Music]
all right children who's ready to go on
a field trip to see the stars you mean
somewhere like a planetarium or a museum
please let this be a normal field trip
as if you know that's not how the frizz
rolls oh has anyone seen Matt we're
going to blast off towards the heavens
for science
uh Miss Frizzle blasting off in three
Miss Russell we're missing mad
[Music]
hello Internet welcome to film Theory
where it's time for a pop quiz question
one do you recognize this voice it's me
head editor Dan hi hello Matt loss's
voice of VidCon so you got me question
two are you subscribed are you are you
sure you should probably go double check
good a plus for you loyal theorist now
it probably wouldn't come as any
surprise to you that I liked me some
science class in grade school why else
would I edit for these channels fun fact
in the third grade I was so into science
that they let me go to challenge which
is where we just basically made slime
for an hour now if only I had the
foresight to make a YouTube channel
imagine the amount of money I could have
made but anyway you knew a day in
science class was going to be extra
special when the teacher wheeled in that
ginormous CRT TV and popped in a VHS
tape packed with some classic good old
edutainment
yes thank you I'm totally aware that I
just aged Myself by mentioning VHS I'm
an internet Boomer and I'm dealing with
it but something nerds of the 90s odds
in 20 teens can all agree on though the
Magic School Bus was freaking awesome
Miss Frizzle was the embodiment of the
perfect teacher engaging her class with
legitimately interesting topics and
taking our students on wacky field trips
to give some real Hands-On learning
whether it was traveling through time to
visit the age of the dinosaurs or that
one time when they traveled inside one
of the students Arnold to study the
human body or when the whole class got
turned into bees
yeah okay sometimes those trips were a
bit um well how do I put this uh mildly
dangerous and life-threatening but also
theorizable oh definitely but Matt
insisted that he wasn't going to ruin
his own childhood that lasted a whole
day before he came in and said quote
okay fine let's just ruin everything so
we dusted off our VCRs kick backed on
the couch and creative director Lee
pointed out that we can't watch the VCR
on the modern TV so we just streamed it
and from the first episode of The Magic
School Bus Gets Lost in Space our
theorist sensibilities got the best of
us in this episode a mundane trip to the
Planetarium is scrapped due to Miss
Frizzle not calling ahead to see if it
was open she then decides to do the next
best thing and kidnap SAI mean escorts
the children to the cosmos and takes a
tour around the solar system they visit
the sun some of the planets and the trip
culminates with the gang landing on
Pluto which was the ninth and final
Planet when the show aired and as much
as it hurts that this guy got demoted to
a dwarf planet I heard about Pluto
it's messed up right it was totally
justified there are five confirmed dwarf
planets in our system and if Pluto is a
planet they all are ripperonis anyway
near the very end of the very first
episode as the class are exploring the
surface of the gimli-sized Pluto one of
the kids Arnold has had enough in a fit
of rage he rips off his space helmet and
instantly freezes I mean one second and
boom he looks like one of those janky
Sonic the Hedgehog ice cream pops you
get from an ice cream truck now hold up
hold up hold up I know I'm trying to
enjoy this as some fun romp through some
clinton-era edutainment but that can't
be possible right I know space is cold
but you can't just go from Annoying
Arnold to X-Men Iceman in an instant can
you so like the very normal human being
Matt is he dove into the scientific
realism of this 90s cartoon with a
magical type a school bus just a very
normal thing to do because while looking
into the truth behind the science here
Matt fell into a rabbit hole bigger than
our own solar system you see loyal
theorists Miss frizzle's Antics would
have gotten the whole class killed many
times over before they reached the edge
of the solar system dooming not only
Arnold but all of the kids in the
classroom two painful deaths worse than
what we could have imagined buckle up
friends this one's gonna be a wild ride
so to explain I guess we should start
with the final scene and move backwards
from there as I just explained after
ripping off his helmet Arnold transforms
into Frosty the Snowman pretty much
instantly so would that really happen
well at first glance it's not as
ridiculous as you might think see deep
space is cold like stupid cold according
to NASA the surface temperature of Pluto
reaches a frostbite-inducing negative
400 degrees Fahrenheit that's negative
240 degrees Celsius just to give you a
comparison here the coldest temperature
ever recorded on Earth was in Antarctica
at negative
89.2 degrees Celsius or negative 128.6
Fahrenheit so when Arnold takes off his
helmet he's a goner right well not
necessarily and to understand why we
need to discuss what temperature is at
an atomic level when we talk about the
temperature of something whether it's
the frigid vacuum of space or that
scalding cup of coffee you spilled in
your lap what we are actually talking
about is how much the molecules in said
empty space or boiling seed soup are
bouncing into each other when two
molecules Collide they release a small
amount of energy in the form of heat the
more collisions the more heat is
released and the higher the temperature
of something is when something hot makes
contact with something cold like say I
don't know the face of a red-headed
fourth grader being exposed to The Bleak
void of space that energy transfers from
the hot thing to the cold thing until it
evens out fun fact there is a limit to
how cold something can be this is known
as absolute zero which is the point
where the molecules don't move at all
and thus don't release any heat and when
you look at that number which is
negative 2
273.15 Celsius or negative
459.67 Fahrenheit or zero Kelvin for you
nerds out there it's pretty close to
that surface temperature of Pluto
however despite the nearly 500 degree
difference between the average human
temperature of 37 degrees Celsius or
98.6 Fahrenheit it's not like all of
Arnold's heat is going to rush out at
once it would take somewhere between 12
to 26 hours for a human to freeze solid
out in space and given that only
Arnold's head is directly exposed that
would likely take much longer and
thankfully the kids think quickly and
get Arnold back on the school bus in a
matter of seconds so while it wouldn't
be comfortable Arnold wouldn't be
becoming an ice sculpture as quickly as
we see in the cartoon and speaking of
where is the world's best teacher Miss
Frizzle well she's standing by as her
students are being the responsible ones
in saving their friend her principal is
probably going to have to have a word
with her when they get back to Earth now
while Arnold might survive his brief
encounter with the chill of Pluto this
little maneuver still still would have
killed them just not for the reasons you
might expect as soon as Arnold takes off
the helmet the pressure of the oxygen
inside his lungs would be released into
space like a shaken up can of Diet Coke
we briefly touched on this in our
episode about portal 2's brief Pit Stop
on the moon over on our sister location
Game Theory but it's worth reiterating
here a Dan cybert survival tip if you
were ever stupid enough to remove your
helmet off in space don't hold your
breath why because as I just said in a
vacuum all the oxygen in your lungs
immediately wants to expand and rush out
into the void and if you hold your
breath then there's nowhere for that
oxygen to go except tearing through your
lungs I don't know about you but if my
choices are gasping for air or ruptured
lungs I'm gonna pick the option that
doesn't cause one of my major organs to
you now literally explode it doesn't
look like Arnold makes a point to empty
his lungs in this scene so while the
cold might not have killed him the
ruptured lungs might have just might
have but even if he did breathe out
before taking off his helmet the whole
no oxygen thing is obviously going to be
bad news for Arnold without oxygen
flowing through your bloodstream your
organs and especially your brain would
begin to shut down after about three
minutes but that's three whole minutes
to get somewhere where you can breathe
again the quick thinking from the other
kids likely did save Arnold's life here
making most of this memorable scene
something entirely survivable but well
as I alluded at the top of this episode
Arnold in the rest of the class wouldn't
have ever made it to Pluto just before
the gang reaches Pluto they take a jaunt
around the outermost planets in the
solar system known collectively as the
gas giants say pass by this planet I'll
let you decide if you want to giggle at
Uranus or Uranus as well as Neptune and
observe the rings of Saturn without much
fanfare also worth noting that the
children are driving the bus at this
point because Miss Frizzle has gone
M.I.A and has turned finding her within
the depths of space into a game
great now it's a riddle okay you know
the more I talk about this the more I'm
like Miss Frizzle is really
irresponsible wasn't she who not only
lost
to do what are we gonna do what are we
gonna do yeah it's gonna take more than
a trip to the guidance counselor's
office to work through this trauma
anyway the gas giant they actually spend
time at is Jupiter the largest planet in
our solar system and what do they do
they fly right into the great red spot
now if you've seen a picture of Jupiter
you probably recognize this thing it's
one of the planet's most iconic features
but what you might not know that it's
not just a cool aesthetic feature or a
beauty mark it's a massive
hurricane-like storm that's been raging
since at least the 1830s and what's more
as of April 3rd 2017 the storm is
approximately 16
350 kilometers in width 10
160 miles meaning that Jupiter's Great
Red Spot is wider than the entire Earth
in size isn't the only frightening
Factor the storm has going for it its
speed is also insane the fastest wind
speed ever recorded on Earth was a
blistering 231 miles per hour or about
372 kilometers per hour recorded on
Mount Washington in New Hampshire in
1934. but wind speeds in the Great Red
Spot can reach upwards to 400 miles per
hour or about
644 kilometers per hour just under
double the speeds on earth now flying
into the dense atmosphere of Jupiter
with speeds that fast would easily tear
a typical school bus to shreds but this
is a Magic School Bus after all so I'll
leave that be but magic wouldn't protect
the kids from letting the Storm Into the
bus in order to collect proof of their
visit the kids open a spigot that allows
the gases of the red spot to pour into
the bus now with those 400 miles per
hour speeds this would be like opening a
window on the fastest train but that is
nothing compared to the sheer weight of
the atmosphere that would begin pouring
into the bus at that incredible speed
remember earlier when we talked about
all of the air wanting to get out of
Arnold's lungs in the vacuum on Pluto
that happens because of air pressure
basically how much the air inside of
something pushes up against the walls of
its container since there isn't a ton of
gas in Pluto's atmosphere the air
pressure would be higher in Arnold's
lungs than on Pluto but on Jupiter you
have the opposite problem the air
pressure on the quote-unquote surface of
Jupiter is roughly 5 to 10 times that of
Earth for say the interior of a Magic
School Bus meant to keep earthlings
comfortable long and short of it is
Jovian gas wouldn't just trickle him
with the spigot it would instantly flood
the interior of the bus and that could
cause some serious complications
depending on what it's made of despite
Decades of study scientists aren't a
hundred percent sure what the big red
spot is made of some theories suggest
it's ammonia reacting to acetylene both
of which would burn the inside of your
lungs and throw it on contact others
suggest that the red spot like the rest
of Jupiter is composed of hydrogen and
helium either way this would be awful
news for the children who would likely
be thrown around by the 400 miles per
hour wind spewing toxic or unbreathable
gases into the bus's cabin and
frighteningly this would likely be the
least painful cause of death for these
kids on this field trip from Hell before
suffocating on Jupiter the class Dodges
some asteroids in the asteroid belt and
makes a quick pit stop to Mars now
without a magnetic field in a painfully
thin atmosphere a prolonged stay on the
Martian surface could be dangerous due
to radiation exposure but that's nothing
compared to the dangers of the class
landing on Venus let's just say things
wouldn't be looking so hot for Miss
frizzle's class after this actually
scratch that things would be looking
very hot see despite being further from
the Sun than Mercury Venus is actually
the hottest planet in the solar system
with this average surface temperatures
racing 850 degrees Fahrenheit or
454 degrees Celsius that's 10 times
hotter than a painfully warm 85 degree
day here on Earth why is it like this
well 96.5 percent of the the Venetian
atmosphere is made of carbon dioxide and
if you know anything about CO2 here on
Earth you'll know that it's a greenhouse
gas that means it likes to absorb the
heat coming from the Sun Earth's
atmosphere is approximately 0.04 percent
carbon dioxide so that 96.5 figure
that's insane and it's basically turned
Venus's atmosphere into a giant blanket
that's holding in all of the heat it
absorbs over a few million or billion
years it's so hot that even metals like
leads start to melt at those
temperatures the longest a space probe
has ever landed on the surface of Venus
is just over two hours if something the
smartest scientists on the planet
literally built and designed to work on
Venus couldn't even Outlast the run time
of an Avatar movie this would mean that
Miss frizzle's class would be dismissed
pretty much the moment they step out
onto the surface and even if they
somehow survived this hellscape of heat
they'd rather be dead the next time it
rained because one of those clouds made
of Miss Frizzle it's sulfuric acid
sulfuric acid
it's a deadly poison speaking of utterly
painful death man what a transition you
pretty much encounter all of the same
issues on the bright side of mercury
which can reach temperatures of roughly
800 degrees Fahrenheit or
427 degrees Celsius but that that would
be nothing compared to what comes next
since Miss Frizzle decides to start this
field trip of death and destruction by
visiting the sun you know how you're
told constantly to not look at the sun
without some serious eye protection
that's because even here on Earth
92 Million Miles Away From the Sun and
with a thick atmosphere protecting us
from the worst of it the star R planet
orbits outputs so much light and energy
that it can permanently damage your
retinas in under two minutes now imagine
driving directly up to the sun getting
closer than any man-made object to be
fair to Miss Frizzle she does realize
this and has the class wear special
heavy duty sunblocked 8 000 Sun goggles
but your eyes aren't what you should be
worrying about here it's a bit difficult
to tell exactly how close the class gets
but we do see the bus flying close to a
plume of plasma that blasts off the
solar surface these are known as coronal
mass ejections which can sometimes
stretch as far as a million miles away
from the sun's surface which means that
at best the bus just traveled within a
million miles of our local star that
might sound like it's far but in terms
of astronomical distances it isn't the
sun is Big loyal theorists I'm sure you
knew that and getting that close would
be devastating the Parker solar probe
which is on its way to the sun right now
will be the closest man-made object ever
to go near the sun it was specifically
designed to get close to our star but at
its closest it will still be about 4
million miles away at about 3 million
miles away the temperatures of just
being near the sun will already be
enough to cause those NASA spacesuits to
fail basically if you were really going
to get close to the Sun it would look
less like a fun edutainment cartoon and
more like the sci-fi horror movie
Sunshine so every step of the way every
planet these kids stopped on would have
been a death trap for them except the
one that created such a terrifyingly
memorable moment ironically enough but
here's the thing loyal theorists it's
not just the planets that would have
hurt these kids Miss Frizzle doomed
these children to a long agonizing
painful death before they even set foot
on another planetary body or flew too
close to the sun and it all comes down
to one thing radiation see there's a lot
of radiation in space and I mean a lot
but there are special kinds that you
should be extra concerned with if you
ever find yourself in Space the first is
solar radiation while we're on Earth we
don't have to worry about this stuff as
I mentioned earlier when we briefly
talked about Mars an atmospheric or
electromagnetic field protects us from
most of this stuff and even the things
that get through ultraviolet light can
be negated by slathering on a layer of
sunscreen but in space there's nothing
to block the dangerous solar particle
events Galactic cosmic rays ionizing
radiation like x-rays or gamma rays that
the sun emits and no I don't mean the
sort of gamma radiation that turns you
into the Fantastic Four or the
Incredible Hulk this stuff is much less
cool damaging your DNA in ways that give
you cancer instead of superpowers NASA
specifically builds their spaceships
space stations and space suits to Shield
the astronauts from this sort of
radiation that's partially why the suits
are so bulky and why they have those
cool golden visors both details that the
Magic School Bus spacesuits don't have
and as a result these particles would be
cutting through kids like a radioactive
knife through children shaped butter
likely making the kids very very sick
just by exiting Earth's atmosphere in
the end every decision Miss Frizzle made
along this field trip from allowing the
kids to collect Jovian gas to stop it by
on the surface of Venus and Mercury to
flying by the sun it even just exiting
the Earth's atmosphere without the
proper precautions would have led to the
deaths of these children multiple times
over she exposed them to lethal doses of
radiation subjected them to inhumane
temperatures and left them to get
crushed and suffocated in a hurricane
literally bigger than Earth while I love
learning and passing on knowledge doing
so in this way was irresponsible these
kids should have been scared far sooner
than when Arnold took off his helmet the
one thing in this trip that ironically
they would have survived with minimal
injuries all in all Miss Frizzle gets an
F for fired and yet despite all this
information matters having me read I
would want nothing more than to go on
this field trip I want to go to space
but hey that's just a theory a film
Theory and cut
Man kids program could sometimes be
scary and hey what we got some more
videos just like that you can go ahead
and click this one about Paw Patrol and
how well that one's a little spooky and
then oh what's this this is a Bluey
episode and it's about why it's kind of
spooky despite how much I love this this
show anyway I um yossi play me out